many soft bots are little better than
velu names they're flexible and move by
inflating in one direction now
researchers are looking into creating
complex soft BOTS that can reversibly
change shape they based their approach
on cephalopods like octopuses and
cuttlefish these animals not only change
the color of their skin but also its
shape and texture they're able to raise
papillae by activating muscles that
encircle areas of skin and muscle the
muscles within the circle dictate the
shape of the raised area researchers
emulated this in silicone inflatable
skins using a mesh of fiber embedded in
the layers the elastomer skin stretches
when inflated with air and the embedded
mesh provides reinforcement much like a
string wrapped around a balloon will
change its shape the mesh restricts
stretching in certain areas controlling
the overall 3d shape they went even
further and made the Rings different
sizes shapes and arrangements building
camouflage rocks and a succulent plant
they even created one that glows in the
dark
these are complex shapes but they're the
only ones these skins can make but this
is only the beginning of camouflaging
robot skins to come are more complex
textures and more selective activation
of shapes and colors someday these skins
or camouflage robots may be used for
hiding observation devices in the field
and disguising machines in natural
spaces
[Music]
[Music]